you co-authored a paper titled Photon
rings around warped black holes first of
all whoever writes your paper titles
you like uh the soft hair and the and
any the term black hole in the Big Bang
you're very good at coming up with
titles yourself anyway you co-authored a
paper title Photon rings around warped
black holes in it you write quote recent
work has identified a number of emergent
symmetries related to the intricate
self-similar structure of the photon
ring so what are Photon Rings what are
some interesting characteristics of a
photon ring
um so that was a paper with Dan coppets
and Alex lipska that just came out
and this is uh paper is kind of a
wonderful example
of what happens
when you start to talk to people who are
you know way out of your comfort zone of
those different stuff and look at the
world a different way and
and some two or three years ago I'm I'm
part of this uh
the black hole initiative I'm also part
of this event horizon telescope
collaboration that took the famous uh
though I had nothing to do with the
experiment but uh that that took the
famous picture of the of the Donut of of
m87 and
um through conversations with them
which started out in an effort
to understand the image that they'd seen
so it's a great thing for somebody like
me a theoretical physicist
lost
seemingly lost in string land
to be presented with an actual picture
of a black hole and ask and to be yes to
be asked what can we learn from this
so you know with some help uh from uh
you know Michael Johnson alexka
um and a bunch of other people
venturized in collaboration
we came up with a fantastic beautiful
answer using Einstein's theory
that
um is both
shaping the future
of now it is shaping the future of
improved photo black hole photographs
what do you want to concentrate on in
the photograph you know just point at
the sky and click no you don't do that
you you optimize for various features
and um it's it's both shaping that and
in the process of
talking to them and thinking about how
light behaves around a black hole
it they black holes just have so many
magic tricks and they do so many weird
things
and the photon ring is among the
weirdest of them we understood the this
Photon ring and in the process of this
we said hey this Photon ring
has got to be telling us something
about the puzzle
of where the holographic plate is
um outside of a ordinary astrophysical
black hole
and we nailed it for the stringy black
holes
but they have a somewhat different
character with a stringy black hole the
the black holes that describe us the
black holes that are contained in string
theory and they have different structure
in them well basically can we step back
so what was the light in the image taken
in 2019 or not not taken to 2018
um uh presented in 2000 so here's the
puzzle
um what they really saw
uh so the black holes tend to gather
stuff that swirls around it
yeah and they don't know what that stuff
is made of they don't know what its
temperature is they don't know what kind
of magnetic fields there are around
there
so
the form of the image has a lot of
unknowns in it that it's dependent on
many other things other than the
geometry of the black hole
sure so most of what you're learning
is about the stuff
now the stuff the swirling stuff the hot
swirling stuff
is interesting as hell
but it's not as interesting as the black
hole which are the which are the most in
my view
the most interesting things in the
universe so you don't want to just learn
about the stuff you want to learn about
the black hole that that it's swirling
around so one of the
at the very first step of the very
primitive level this is just a big leap
for human civilization to be able to see
a black hole and the way you can see it
is because there's stuff around it but
you don't get to learn much about the
black hole you get to learn more about
the stuff just from the image yeah okay
but you're not going to learn about the
details before you've even seen it
because there's too many parameters
there's too many variables that govern
the stuff yeah so then we found a very
wonderful way
to learn about the black hole and here's
how it works
a black hole is a mirror
and the way it's a mirror is if light a
photon bounces off your face
towards the black hole and it goes
straight to the black hole just Falls in
you never see it again
but if it just misses the black hole
it'll swing around the back and come
back to you
and you see yourself
from the photon that went around the
back of the black hole
but not only can that happen
the black hole the photon can swing
around twice
and come back so you actually see an
infinite number of copies
of yourself like with a little bit of a
delay
with a little bit of a delay right
this is awesome yeah and in fact I mean
we're not used to an object that bends
light like that right yeah so you're
going to get some trippier graphics and
and in fact one of my my students has
made a really awesome computer animation
of this which I'm gonna show at a public
lecture in a couple weeks where the
audience will see infinitely many copies
of themselves
and I'll swirling around the black hole
so
if you so it's a black hole is like a
Hall of Mirrors you know like a
department store where you go and
there's there's the three mirrors and
you see infinitely many copies of
yourself yeah
think of the black hole as the mirror
you know and you know you go in there
with your clothes if you want to know
about your clothes you just look at the
direct image you're not learning
anything about the configuration of
mirrors
but the relation
of of
[Music]
um
the image you see in front of you
to the one you see at the side and the
next one and then so on
depends only on the mirrors it doesn't
matter what clothes you're wearing
so you can go there a thousand times
wearing different clothes but each time
there will be the same relation between
the subsequent images
and that is how
we're going to learn about the black
holes
we're going to take the stuff that is
swirling around
and we're going to tease out the
subsequent images and look at their
relation
and there's some very beautiful
really beautiful mathematics which we
were surprised to realize with the
volumes and volumes of
papers on
black holes in their properties this
particular
because it was a physical question that
had never been asked in exactly this way
so basically you're looking at the
relationship the subsequent images the
relationship but those are ultimately
formed by photons that are swirling
around the photons that are orbiting so
the photon ring
are the photons that orbit around and
Beyond so like orbit and lose orbit like
they are they yeah like so
uh wow and that starts to give you what
can you possibly figure out
mathematically about the black hole can
you the geometry of it does this
geometry the spin
um and you can verify
things behaving you know we have never
seen
a region of space-time
with such high curvature I mean yeah the
region around a black hole is crazy it's
not like in this room right the
curvature is everything you know you
spend probably enough time with the math
and the photons
can you
put yourself in that space so we're like
having a conversation pretty peaceful
comfortable flat space are you able to
put yourself in in a place around a
black hole yeah I'm able to imagine that
kind of thing yeah so for example and
actually there's a wonderful movie
um
Interstellar yeah
and
um
in that movie you know Kip Thorne of
course is a great
theoretical physicists experimental who
later won the Nobel Prize
um for ligo and that movie is very
accurate scientifically
and there's some funny statements in
there
that
of the
you know 100 million people who saw that
movie there can't be more than 10 or 20
understood
about why Matthew McConaughey is
ejecting the trash in a certain
direction in order to
but you know for example if I wear a
spinning black hole right here if I was
spinning fast enough
you wouldn't be able to stay still there
you'd be have to be orbiting around like
that you know you'd have to have your
microphone on them but I wonder what the
experiences with the actual experience
because I mean space itself is curved
well space gets very curved you get
crushed
you know the body gets ripped apart
because the forces are different on
different parts sure okay so that would
be but if it but if it can be less
curved so that the curvature is very
noticeable but you're not ripped apart
the fact that this was just nonchalantly
stated is is just beautiful like two
biological systems discussing uh which
level of curvature is required to rip
apart said biological system very well
um so you propose in the paper that a
photon ring of a warped black hole is
indeed part of the black hole hologram
a photon ring of a warped black hole is
uh so what can you Intuit about the
hologram
and the the holographic plate
from looking at the photon rings
well this paper
is exploring a new idea it's not make
it's not
it's it's not making a new
Discovery so to speak
it's exploring an idea and and and and
um the ins and outs of it and and what
might work and
and what might not and this Photon ring
somehow everybody always thought that
the holographic plate sat at the Horizon
of the black hole right
and that the quantum system
that describes the black hole is inside
the horizon
and it in fact
um we think
it's plausible
and we give some evidence in some
soluble examples in this case in an
example in one lower Dimension where we
can handle the equations better that the
quantum system that describes the black
hole
should correspond to a region of
space-time which is includes the photon
ring
so it's bigger hmm
so that that would be the holographic
please that would be the holographic
play all of that I mean we didn't prove
this
we we
uh you know we put it out there which
hadn't really been considered previously
we put it out there and
um it does seem more plausible than the
idea that it sits literally at the
Horizon and it is a big
outstanding problem of of how you have a
holographic reconstruction of black
holes like m87
do you think uh there could be
experimental further experimental data
that helps explore some of these ideas
that you have for Photon rings and
holographic plates through Imaging and
through so like higher and higher
resolution images and also just more and
more data I wish so but I don't think so
and but what I think already has
happened and will continue happen
is that the you know there there are
many different ways that
uh theorists and
observers can interact
the gold standard
is the theorist makes a prediction The
Observer
measures it and confirms it or the
uh makes it this
Discovery and the theorist explains it
but there's a lot less than that which
is really kind of the bread and butter
of those are dramatic moments when that
happens right those are once in a
lifetime moments when that happens but
the bread and butter is more when inador
has already happened
they came to us and said what what is
the interesting theoretical things we
can understand
in this swirl around the black hole and
we give an answer and then that
in turn jogged us to
think about the holographic principle in
the context of
m87 a little bit differently and so it's
a useful and in the same vein it's
useful to talk to the philosophers and
it's useful to talk to the
mathematicians and you know a lot of
you gotta we just gotta you know we
don't know where we're going we just
gotta like
do everything